House of the Dragon is a Game
of Thrones prequel show that is
confirmed by HBO’s president to air in 2022.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet
unfinished Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the legendary
Aegon the Conqueror, creator of the Iron Throne,
and goes on to recount the generations of
Targaryens who fought to hold that iconic seat,
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
That's Fire And Blood volume 1. The
yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve as
showrunners and executive producers. George R.
R. Martin will also serve as executive producer.
The key event of the prequel will be the
Dance of the Dragon, a Targaryen civil war.
Although it's a Targaryen civil war, Targaryens
are not the only key characters from this time
period, one major character among them being
Corlys Velaryon, known as the Sea Snake.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon
II and his half-sister Rhaenyra over
their father Viserys I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged
on the Iron Throne. When people started
declaring for one of them or the other,
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
As I already said, Game of Thrones prequel series,
House of the Dragon, though based on the George
RR Martin's Targaryen history book Fire & Blood,
will not feature Targaryens only
but many other houses and many other
legendary figures from that time period as well,
including the Velaryons had for centuries remained
the oldest and closest allies of the Targaryens.
The sea was their element, not the sky.
During the Conquest, it was Velaryon ships that
carried Aegon’s soldiers across Blackwater Bay,
and later formed the greater
part of the royal fleet.
The most famous and strongest Velaryion to
ever live is also one of the main characters
in the upcoming House of the Dragon show
- Corlys Velaryon, known as the Sea Snake.
He is a fabled Lord of the Tides
during Targaryen civil war,
Master of Driftmark, and head of House Velaryon.
House Velaryon, much like House Targaryen,
is of Valyrian descent, and
its members often have Valyrian
features, such as silver hair, purple eyes.
He was the husband of Princess Rhaenys Targaryen,
the Queen-Who-Never-Was. During the Dance of
the Dragons, he became Hand to Queen Rhaenyra
Targaryen who was his niece and daughter-in-law.
By the of age seven-and-thirty, Corlys was
hailed as the greatest seafarer
the Seven Kingdoms had ever known.
Corlys was born in 53 AC to the
eldest son of Lord Daemon Velaryon.
He was named after his
great-great-uncle, Ser Corlys Velaryon,
who served King Aegon the Conqueror as the
first Lord Commander of the Kingsguard.
Ser Corlys sailed aboard his Sea Snake, a
ship he designed and built, on nine great
voyages to Essos. During his final voyage on Sea
Snake, Corlys filled the ship's hold with gold
and bought twenty more ships at Qarth,
loading them with spices, elephants, and silk.
Only fourteen ships reached
Driftmark and all the elephants died,
but it was still more than enough to make Corlys
become the wealthiest man in all of Westeros.
He took his nickname "Sea
Snake" from his famous ship.
Ser Corlys became head of House Velaryon and Lord
of the Tides after the death of his grandsire.
Richer than Lords Lannister or Hightower
through his expeditions, Lord Corlys used
his great wealth to construct a new seat, High
Tide, where he stored his eastern treasures.
In 90 AC, Corlys married the sixteen-year-old
Princess Rhaenys Targaryen, the only child of
Prince Aemon Targaryen, who in turn was the
eldest son of King Jaehaerys I Targaryen.
Two years later, Corlys sailed his fleet to Tarth,
to aid Prince Aemon in fighting the Myrish exiles
who had invaded the island. Shortly before they
left, Corlys's wife announced she was pregnant.
During the campaign, Prince Aemon died, leading
King Jaehaerys I Targaryen to appoint a new heir
to the throne. He chose his second son
Baelon over Aemon's only heir, Rhaenys,
thereby also passing over Corlys and Rhaenys's
unborn child. Furious over this decision, Corlys
gave up his admiralty and his place on the king's
small council and returned to Driftmark with
his wife. In late 92 AC, Rhaenys gave birth to a
daughter, Laena. A son, Laenor, followed in 94 AC.
When Prince Baelon died in 101 AC, King Jaehaerys
I's succession became unclear again, and reports
reached the court that Corlys was gathering
ships and men to defend the rights of his son.
When the king declared a Great Council would
be held at Harrenhal to settle the succession,
Corlys and his wife traveled there,
using their wealth and influence to
try and persuade the lords present to vote
for Laenor, after Rhaenys and Laena had been
passed over once again on account of their gender.
Corlys's fame, reputation, and wealth did much to
support Laenor's claim, but in the end, Baelon's
son Viserys received the majority of the votes
and was named Prince of Dragonstone.
Following the death of Queen Aemma Arryn,
in 105 AC, Grand Maester Runciter suggested to
King Viserys I Targaryen that he take Corlys's
twelve-year-old daughter, Laena, to wife. King
Viserys, however, chose Alicent Hightower.
Angered by the third time his wife and
children had been scorned by House Targaryen,
Corlys and his family did not
attend the wedding in 106 AC.
Instead, he made an alliance with Prince Daemon
Targaryen, King Viserys's younger brother,
equally angered by the king's marriage.
Lord Corlys and his fleets fought alongside
Prince Daemon Targaryen during the War for
the Stepstones. When Daemon declared himself
the King of the Stepstones and the Narrow Sea,
Corlys placed the crown on the new king's head.
In 113 AC, King Viserys I and his small council
began discussions concerning a betrothal for
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen, Viserys's heir.
They eventually agreed on Corlys's son, Laenor.
Laenor and Rhaenyra were married
in 114 AC and gave him 3 grandsons.
By 115 AC, Corlys saw his daughter Laena wed to
Daemon with his blessing. Through this marriage,
Corlys would have two more grandchildren: the twin
girls Baela and Rhaena Targaryen, born in 116 AC.
The children of Corlys and Princess
Rhaenys Targaryen both died in 120 AC,
Laena Velaryon from childbed fever and Ser Laenor
Velaryon from a quarrel with a knight which is
rumored to have been organized by Daemon. Later
in the same year Prince Daemon, Laena's widower,
married Princess Rhaenyra
Targaryen, Laenor's widow.
Lord Corlys Velaryon sat on the black council
during the civil war known as the Dance of the
Dragons; he was the greatest lord to pledge his
strength to the cause of Queen Rhaenyra Targaryen,
who was opposed by her half-brother, King Aegon II
Targaryen. More than half of Rhaenyra's army was
made up of men sworn to House Velaryon. Corlys's
fleets also gave the blacks superiority at sea.
When Lord Bartimos Celtigar urged the princess
to fly from Dragonstone to King’s Landing at once
and reduce the city to ash and bone with
her dragon, Corlys demanded to know how
that would serve them, telling him "we want
to rule the city, not burn it to the ground".
The Sea Snake commanded the Velaryon
fleet when it closed off the Gullet
and sailed back and forth from Dragonstone and
Driftmark, blocking all shipping entering or
leaving Blackwater Bay and thereby choking
off trade to and from King's Landing.
Eventually, the Velaryon blockade was broken by
the Battle in the Gullet and High Tide was sacked.
When his wife Rhaenys flew to Rook's
Rest to give aid to Lord Staunton,
who was besieged by the forces of Aegon II, she
fell in battle against King Aegon II and Sunfyre,
and Prince Aemond Targaryen and Vhagar. When
news of Rhaenys's death reached Dragonstone,
Corlys blamed Rhaenyra for Rhaenys's death, as she
had forbidden her sons from accompanying Rhaenys.
In late 129 AC, Rhaenyra's son, Prince
Jacaerys brought the Lord of the Tides back
into the fold by naming him Hand of the Queen.
Together the Hand and Jacaerys planned an assault
upon King’s Landing. Not long after, one of the
riderless dragons, Seasmoke, took onto his back
a fifteen-year-old boy known as Addam of Hull.
Lord Corlys went so far as to petition Queen
Rhaenyra to remove the taint of bastardy
from Addam and his brother, Alyn.
The queen complied and Addam Velaryon
became Corlys's heir to Driftmark.
After the queen took King's Landing, as
Lord Ormund Hightower's host advanced
slowly on King's Landing, with Prince
Daeron scouting ahead on his dragon,
Lord Corlys suggested to Rhaenyra
that the time had come to talk.
He urged the queen to offer pardons to Lord Borros
Baratheon, Ormund Hightower and House Lannister.
He proposed to let the Faith of the Seven take
charge of Queen Alicent Hightower and Queen
Helaena Targaryen, so that they might spend the
rest of their lives in prayer and contemplation.
Corlys suggested that Princess Jaehaera
Targaryen, the daughter of Rhaenyra's rival,
King Aegon II, be made his own ward,
and in due time married to Rhaenyra's son,
Prince Aegon the Younger, binding the two
halves of House Targaryen together once again.
Rhaenyra demanded to know what of her half
brothers, Aegon II, Aemond, and Daeron.
Lord Corlys suggested they be spared and sent to
the Wall. When Corlys mentioned the sacred vows
of the Night's Watch, Rhaenyra questioned the
vows of oathbreakers, stating that "Their vows
did not trouble them when they took my throne."
Her husband, Prince Daemon, echoed the queen's
misgiving and suggested a hard line, but
the queen decided to steer a middle course.
After the Two Betrayers switched sides, Lord
Corlys was the only person on the black council
to speak in defense of the dragonseed. He remarked
that Ser Addam and his brother Alyn were "true
heirs" and worthy of Driftmark and that Nettles
had fought valiantly in the Battle in the Gullet.
The Hand's impassioned protests were in vain as
by this time the queen had been betrayed so often,
by so many, that she was quick to believe the
worst of any man. Queen Rhaenyra commanded
Ser Luthor Largent to arrest Addam in the
Dragonpit. Addam, who had been forewarned,
managed to make his escape
by flying away with Seasmoke.
When the balked and angry Luthor
returned from the Dragonpit,
he accused Corlys of treachery. Corlys did not
deny it. Bound and beaten, but still silent,
he was taken down into the Red Keep's dungeons
and thrown into a black cell to await trial and
execution. This action lost Rhaenyra her fleet.
When it became known that Corlys had been
arrested, his men, who made up half of
Rhaenyra's forces at King's Landing,
began to abandon Rhaenyra by the hundreds.
This was the beginning of Rhaenyra's downfall
which eventually cost her her life.
Once Aegon II Targaryen returned to
King's Landing after feeding Rhaenyra to his
dragon, Lord Corlys was released and pardoned,
allowing him to serve Aegon on his small council.
Corlys did not simply betray the remaining members
of the Blacks who were still in the field:
originally Aegon II considered executing Aegon
III, who was (for all anyone knew) Rhaenyra's
last remaining child. But Aegon II needed the
wealth of House Velaryon and to ensure they
wouldn't continue fighting him, so in return,
Corlys was able to negotiate the concessions
that he would have a seat on the small council,
that Aegon III would be spared, and even that
Aegon III would be betrothed to Aegon II's last
remaining child, Princess Jaehaera.
At one council meeting,
the Sea Snake openly called King Aegon II and his
small council "fools, liars, and oathbreakers"
and stormed out. Lord Larys Strong afterwards
went to Corlys to bring him back on the council,
and together they secretly plotted to end the war.
Following the defeat of Lord Borros Baratheon at
the Battle of the Kingsroad, with an army of
rivermen near the city, and a second host, led
by Lord Cregan Stark, coming down the kingsroad,
Corlys advised Aegon II to join the Night's
Watch. The king refused but was mysteriously
poisoned soon after, thereby ending the war.
Following the death of Aegon II Targaryen, and
before the arrival of the Wolf of Winterfell
who wanted to continue the war until all
late Rhaenyra's enemies were destroyed,
Corlys sent envoys to Casterly Rock,
Storm's End and Oldtown, who had been
Aegon II's main supporters, suing for peace.
Lord Corlys was arrested by Lord Stark
in what became known as the Hour of the Wolf. He
was later freed thanks to an edict of King Aegon
III Targaryen that Baela and Rhaena Targaryen
persuaded him to issue. Black Aly Blackwood
agreed to marry Lord Stark if he honored the
edict, which he did. Thus Corlys was freed and
served as one of the regents of young Aegon III.
Corlys was regarded as the most powerful of the
regents of the young king until his death of
old age in 132 AC, at the age of seventy-nine.
To honor him and all his deeds, his body was
placed beneath the Iron Throne for a week.
Corlys was then carried back to Driftmark where
the battered hull of his ancient ship Sea Snake
was then floated one last time and towed out
into the deep waters with Corlys aboard it.
It was said afterward that as the hull went
down, the wild dragon Cannibal swept overhead,
his great black wings spread in a last salute.
Its only fitting to end this video about the Sea
Snake with briliant writing of Gyldayn in
Fire And Blood, who writes this about him:
''Seventy-nine years of age, he had served four
kings and a queen sailed to the ends of the earth,
raised House Velaryon to unprecedented levels of
wealth and power, married a princess who might
have been a queen, fathered dragonriders,
built towns and fleets, proved his valor in
times of war and his wisdom in times of peace. The
Seven Kingdoms would never see his like again.''
Let me know your thoughts about everything: the
prequel, its characters, especially the Sea Snake,
in the comment section down below. Thank you
soo much for watching. If you enjoyed this
video please give it a big thumbs up and
I hope to see you in the next one. Peace!